there's nothing surprising about most
sequels these days
especially since they seem to be a dime
a dozen thankfully though there are at
least a handful of upcoming projects
that nobody could have seen coming
these are some of the movie sequels you
probably didn't know are happening
before zack snyder's bloody zombie heist
film army of the dead had even premiered
on netflix in 2021
the movie's producers were already
looking ahead to the future of the
franchise
while the ending of the film didn't seem
to leave a lot of room for sequels
the opening sequences suggested plenty
of potential backstory to mine
and that's exactly what netflix is
planning in addition to an anime series
tracing the early days of the zombie
outbreak
titled army of the dead las vegas the
2021 film will also receive a prequel
feature centered around
its expert safecracker ludwig dieter
titled army of thieves the prequel will
be directed by matthias schweigerfer
who will also star as a scene-stealing
criminal the film will be set just as
the zombies are first spreading across
las vegas
an event shown only as a quick epic
montage at the beginning of army of the
dead
according to schneider it will primarily
tell the story of how dieter's safe
cracking career came to be
like army of the dead army of thieves
will also feature an ensemble
cast although schweighoffer will be the
only carryover from the first film
joining him for the prequel will be
natalie emmanuel guz khan
ruby ophe and stuart martin while
netflix hasn't yet given the film a
precise premiere date
it's set to hit the streamer sometime in
2021
long before john boyega was fighting the
first order in star wars he was fighting
far more monstrous aliens in the urban
sci-fi adventure
attack the black written and directed by
joe cornish the 2011 film starred boyega
as moses
the leader of a south london street gang
that decides to rid their neighborhood
of vicious extraterrestrial invaders
a sequel will reunite boyega and cornish
the latter of whom is once again both
writing and directing
this time boyega will also be acting as
co-producer
in addition to reprising his role as
moses speaking to deadline boyega said
it's been a decade since attack the
block was released and so much has
changed since then
i'm excited to see this heightened story
return to the streets of london
moses has remained one of my favorite
characters to play and bringing him back
is a huge honor
cornish echoed his collaborators
enthusiasm saying
i'm thrilled we're officially announcing
our return to the world of attack the
block on the 10th anniversary
of the film's release i can't wait to
work alongside jon again
bringing audiences and even bigger slice
of inner city alien action
although the stephen king novel pet
cemetery has a pretty conclusive ending
the same cannot be said for the 2019
film adaptation
which reimagined the story in a much
more open-ended fashion
so it makes sense that pet cemetery 2 is
now in the works from paramount
which will be helmed by chaos walking
scribe lindsey beer in her directing
debut
the film is said to skip theaters
debuting exclusively on the paramount
plus streaming service
the 2019 remake of the 1989 original
starred jason clark
and amy simons as parents who discover a
small cemetery near their new house
after their cat is hit by a car and
killed they bury him in the cemetery
only for him to come back to life of
course everything goes downhill from
there
and in typical stephen king fashion
things get pretty disturbing pretty
quickly
plot details for the sequel are unknown
but given the ending of the first film
it seems almost certain that it will
feature a new cast
with the only returning character being
the pet cemetery itself
ahead of the release of spyral from the
book of saw the ninth installment in the
saw horror franchise
star chris rock was already campaigning
for a sequel speaking to radiotimes.com
rock said
i hope this movie is like creed and the
sense that creed is technically like
rocky 7.
so hopefully there's more spirals and
hopefully i'm in more spirals
we'll see if people like it we'll see if
people turn out
luckily people have indeed turned out
with spiral pushing the horror franchise
over the one billion dollar mark at the
global box office
by itself the numbers for spiral haven't
been particularly impressive
although it hasn't been a disastrous
showing by any measure especially
considering that it was released in the
midst of the kovid 19 pandemic
as such it was reported ahead of the
movie's release that lionsgate was
actively developing a 10th saw film
although this hasn't been confirmed by
the studio and although spiral director
daryn lynn bausman has warned fans not
to get ahead of themselves
he has admitted that a sequel isn't out
of the question he told radiotimes.com
i think that if spiral is successful
they'll continue it on
but if this has to be successful fans
have to embrace what this is
and if they do embrace it i think
they'll continue on as they have in the
past
the game is afoot again after the smash
success
of 2020s and now the homes netflix's
detective caper starring millie bobby
brown as a younger sister of sherlock
holmes the streamer has greenlit a
sequel
based on a series of novels by nancy
springer the first film saw the teenager
nola running away from home
to investigate her mother's mysterious
disappearance against the explicit
instructions of her older brother
mycroft who steps in as her guardian
during her journey she befriends a
viking chukesbury
a young runaway who's been targeted for
assassination of course by the end of
the film anola has solved both mysteries
as well as earn the respect of her
famous detective sibling
while the plot of the sequel isn't yet
known it will undoubtedly see another
taking on another case
although whether she and sherlock will
work together this time remains to be
seen
brown and henry cavill will both reprise
their roles for the sequel
which will also bring back the
original's director harry bradbeer
at disney's 2020 investor day event the
studio reaffirmed that a fifth
installment in the iconic indiana jones
franchise is on the way
once again starring harrison ford
it's the mileage at 78 years old ford
will likely be retiring his trademark
weapon fedora by the end of indiana
jones 5.
although the studio hasn't yet indicated
whether the film will see him pass the
baton to a younger generation
or close out the franchise for good
however we do know he'll be joined in
his adventure by phoebe waller bridge of
fleabag fame
and hannibal's mass mickelson along with
boyd holbrook
and shawnette renee wilson and they'll
be accompanied by the score of john
williams
who's also returning for indy's newest
adventure in the director's chair for
indy 5 is james mangold
who has already proved that he is
perfectly capable of bringing the legacy
of a beloved action hero to a dignified
end
mangold previously directed 2017's logan
which served as a final adventure for
hugh jackman's wolverine
and patrick stewart's charles xavier
logan earned man golden academy award
nomination for best adapted screenplay
and served as a thrilling and satisfying
conclusion for jackman and stewart's
characters
while indiana jones 5 isn't likely to
skew nearly as dark as logan
we can only hope that it will offer up a
suitably moving farewell to one of
cinema's great action icons the movie
hits theaters on july 29th
2022 after six successful instalments in
the found footage horror franchise
paranormal activity is coming back with
a seventh film
which will once again partner paramount
studios with horror mega producer
jason blum the film will be held by
underwater director will eubank
from a script by christopher landon and
after a little shuffling due to the
kobit 19 pandemic
the decision was made to skip theaters
and release the film directly onto
paramount plus
while no plot details have yet been
released we can take some guesses as to
where the movie is headed
after the first paranormal activity
focused on newlyweds katie and mika
every subsequent installment has tied
back to katie and her family in one way
or another
in particular the paranormal activity
sequels most frequently focus on new
characters
that happen to encounter katie and her
demonic companion
toby enabling the franchise to tell
wider and more intricately intertwined
stories
it seems almost certain that the seventh
movie will continue this trend in some
way
introducing a new group of characters
doomed to have their lives ruined by
katie and her family
keeping with the style of the first six
films you can also bet your bottom
dollar that the movie will also be
presented via a found footage format
that's kind of the whole point despite
the better part of four decades having
passed since the last starfighter first
wowed audiences
the timing may actually be right for a
sequel to the 80s action classic
the original movie follows a teenager
who beats a video game
only to discover that said game was
really a recruiting tool designed to
find
soldiers who can help fight in an
interstellar alien war
obviously video games have changed a lot
since then which could present
a natural way to continue the story
speaking to movie hull
the original movie's writer jonathan
betuel said of the sequel
it's not a remake it's going to continue
the story what's changed this time
itself
certainly as a video world and the alien
world have continued to tick away
it's not a time capsule of the 80s by
any means we're taking it to the next
level
passing the torch or the joystick betsy
well will be co-writing the sequel
titled the last starfighters with rogue
one screenwriter
gary witter in 2021 witter tweeted a
sizzle reel containing hints regarding
the plot of the film
which seems to involve an alien
attempting to assassinate an adult alex
the protagonist of the first film and
alex and heading off into space to
figure out what's going on
according to betuel the road to making a
sequel has been a rocky one
but he's optimistic it will finally get
off the ground betty well said
i had to go through a process that took
years to recapture the rights
but that was recently completed and
although nothing is ever clear sailing
it looks like we have a really good
opportunity now so i'm really looking
forward to taking it up
although 2019's wildly fun whodunit
knives out was written to be
self-contained
director ryan johnson wasted no time in
letting audiences know he'd be open to a
sequel
telling collider if this movie does even
okay i will in a heartbeat make more of
these with daniel
as it turns out knives out did a lot
better than okay
bringing in more than 300 million
dollars worldwide
and justifying not one but two sequels
both of which will go directly to
netflix the move to netflix is a
surprising one
considering that the first film was
distributed theatrically through
lionsgate
but it was the decision of both johnson
and his producing partner ram bergman
to take the sequels directly to the
streaming site both films will follow
daniel craig's drawing private
investigator
benoit blanc but he'll be the only
carryover from the first movie
aside from craig johnson says her
knife's out sequel will each feature a
different cast
different setting and a different donut
shaped mystery for blanc to solve
similar to agatha christie's hercule
poirot novels
which served as an inspiration for the
original movie while no release date has
been said for either sequel the ensemble
cast is shaping up to be every bit as
impressive as the first movie
with knives out 2 set to feature with
catherine hahn dave
bautista janelle monae leslie odom jr
edward norton and kate hudson in
starring roles
it makes no damn sense
compels me though check out one of our
newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite movies are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
you